[Music]
hosannah mayor Pete just found his
running mate
that's Matt Easton BYU's first ever
openly gay Mormon valedictorian anyone
with the courage to come out in an arena
full of latter-day saints can handle
working at this office so I reached
around to him with this tweet and
offered him a job he responded and since
Twitter is legally binding I flew him to
Colver City for a job interview as a
mere formality I've seen your resume
you're overqualified for every job here
but I like to ask everyone who worked
here extremely personal questions you
know I went to BYU so not the first time
I've been asked though so let's do it
okay top or bottom
Wow are you a virgin is being gay at BYU
as hot as it sounds do you hope one day
to have a lot of husbands can I even ask
you if we have everyone working it's
best yeah are you allowed to be gay in
the Mormon Church yes you can be gay you
can't act on being gay so you can't date
get married things like that you know
that's hogwash
right that's like insanity you're
telling me
yeah are you single well you got to be
single at BYU if you're gay yeah college
I don't know if you experienced it the
way you should have maybe you did just
leave it at that is there a lot of gay
people at BYU more than you think one is
more than I thought yeah we're there
there's a community there's a lot of us
we don't have a club on campus are you
allowed to have a club on campus we're
not it's almost like you're like a
secret agent and we have to like respect
all these more what it's like is you
know there's a big brother always
watching me yeah that big brother is God
do you think you've paved the way for
derek hough to come out fingers crossed
so when did you actually come out of the
closet so I came out to my parents about
two years ago my speech three weeks ago
was the first time I really came out was
it terrified or now oh my gosh
absolutely I'm sweating I'm so nervous
you know you're doing a good thing
though thank you people that say like
who cares anymore are just people that
have hate in their hearts um yeah so I
think it is good you thank you what is
it one of the biggest misconceptions
people have about Mormons most of them
are pretty spot-on
do you drink caffeine yeah we drink
caffeine love coca-cola okay I thought
you didn't have caffeine no no coffee
why is coffee the liquid I asked myself
that a lot right so when you ask
yourself that you have to say okay if
this is ridiculous that everything is
ridiculous how can you be the
valedictorian and not see through that
compartmentalize maybe how many brothers
and sisters do I got three you the
oldest or youngest and the third boy
girl boy girl are you the gayest and I'm
absolutely gayest I will say I do have
56 person cuz of me where you gonna be
in five years
hopefully DC who knows where do you
think what are you two years where do
you think you're gonna be maybe your
boss be my boss yeah I'll be your boss
twenty two years there's not a lot of
Mormons in show business that I know of
there are believe it or not gays gay lot
Mormon none Mormon gay you would be the
unicorn
oh okay I've got the perfect position
for you combined your love of biking
door-to-door and my need for more
viewers let's do it
oh I'm severely shaped I hope these
people let us in I need you
[Music]
how can I help you people hi we're
spreading the good news about tosh
point-o it's on every Tuesday at 10:00
p.m. on Comedy Central
do you mind if we come in and set your
DVR sound the door oh hey perfect timing
I was actually supposed to mix mocktails
Joe come on in
oh we were actually get a lot of houses
to get to so I don't think this don't be
such a prude
we didn't make it any other houses we
had a fellowship and with those
interracial fans all night
we woke up so mock hungover
you